right we'll get started then welcome to
the Development Committee 18th October
2018 just our usual announcement should
we be required to evacuate the building
which please leave the building via
nearest available exit to the chamber
our assembly point won't be in the
public car park at the side of the Civic
suite
please don't delay your evacuation by
collecting any belongings please don't
return into the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded and can I remind you to
switch off your phones or turn them to
silent please thank you apologies for
absence
they've been received from counselor
mrs. hoi and counts lamelle an item to
substitute counsel Lucas Gill
substituting for councillor mountain
item three non members attending
goodness he counts the Stanley and
councillor gooding item four minutes of
the meeting held on the 20th of
September 2018 be happy for me to sign
those as a correct and accurate record
of that meeting thank you
item 5 is declarations of interests
counts in Steptoe Thank You chairman
got quite a number so please bear with
me with item 6 & 7
i'm county councillor for ROK's and
south and wor counselor for rockford
south with reference to item 8 1 Rose
Dean County Council of aerobics south
wall council for oxford south and
Barling parish council cancer Arno
councillor Williams Thank You chairman
I've got a few as well Landy's to rugby
rugby tablet item six ward councillor
for that area airport building I'm a
member of the Eppley airs on committee
I'd say Thank You Lucas Gail Ward member
for item six item seven again Ward
member and I'm also on the airport
consultative committee and item eight
Ward member hey can't step toe you want
add more Thank You chairman yes other
councillors who reminded me I'm also a
member of the airport consulted
chemistry thank you
um just for reference it's not necessary
to declare that your award here a
district Ward Ward counselor just for
future reference
okay thank you item six land to the east
of the Rugby Club aviation way Rochford
there's information on the addendum for
this one as well just for reference
chairman this is a reserved matters
application for consideration of the
layout appearance scale and landscaping
in association with works to construct
an employment unit for b1 office and b2
in general industrial use the site area
is outlined in bold on the attach plan
yes sorry can you hear me okay
I'm a bit closer to the southeastern
corner of the wider Business Park is
where this site area is located it was
granted
outline permission in 2016 the wider
business Park and it brought us
commercial units in aviation way is that
bit better can you hear me clearly now
thank you Katie
the existing layer plan shows the
current situation at the wider site a
new roundabout has been identified on
horizon
it's gone the wrong way hello
I'll continue for the time being the
existing layer plan shows the current
situation at the wider site so we've got
a new roundabout constructed within
Cherry Orchard way to the northwest of
the application site along with a
roundabout within the actual business
park itself and a spine road linking to
the approved and west cliff Rugby Club
which is currently under construction if
we'd have plan 3 please thank you and
this so this is an updated indicative
master plan and which has been provided
with the current application it's
showing how the development proposed is
part of the reserve Mathers application
would align with the wider Business Park
so you can see the application currently
before us is this sort of section here
within the wider business park site it
should be noted that the outline
planning application is the overarching
decision which looked at matters
relating to construction management and
106 contributions to name but a few
it is not for the application company
before us to revisit the matters already
considered as part of the outline
application many of which were
controlled by conditions imposed on the
outline application the current reserved
matters proposal includes a large
rectangular building in this location
here I'm providing manufacturing office
and other ancillary space for the
intended operator
Ipek o there'll be two access to the
site one from the main looped spine road
so that would be in this location here
which would provide access to a parking
area to the north of the building yeah
the other would be from the spine Road
and will provide access to a service
yard and refuse areas so that's this one
here that's where the service yard area
would be located soft landscaping would
also surround the sites in various
locations around the border so this plan
shows the intended design of the
building the walls would include metal
sheet cutting in black and gray coloring
installed horizontally and vertically
across the elevations the key material
planning considerations are access
parking layout appearance scale and
landscaping with regard to access County
highways an object to the proposal
subject to a condition regarding
visibility sleighs
they refer to the need for the gate
control dispute to be set back to allow
HGB to sound clear of a carriageway the
gate control was conditioned as part of
our previous reserved matters
application and would be addressed
through a discharge of condition the
proposed access arrangements are not
considered
objectionable here the parking repose
will shows 226 parking spaces the
parking standards document requires 268
however such requirement is a maximum
figure within our within our document
guidance cycle provision meets policy
and the power to wheeler provision is
slightly below the requirement however a
condition has been suggested to address
this use of the minimum parking bays is
proposed concern was raised with regards
to this within the officer report and a
condition suggested to address this
however its considered that as the
outline design codes showed use of the
minimum bays and because the applicant
has now provided what they consider to
be exceptional circumstances the use of
the minimum bays would be acceptable
members may be aware that the council
lost an appeal seeking to enforce some
preferred parking bays at KS KFC which
are very nearby which has similar
characteristics to the site before us we
regards to layout County urban design
had provided detailed comments they
advised that surveillance could have
been improved for changing layer on
furnace tration officers consider the
general lay arrangements for the sites
are acceptable here the appearance so
the height of the building is 10.5
metres which adheres to the design code
within the approved outline application
the design includes to gently code roof
form so you can see that here which adds
visual interest as well as reference in
the form and appearance of an aircraft
hangar the materials proposed a fit for
purpose and adhere to the principles of
the design code County urban design
officer raises concern as a design cone
advises that buildings along the rural
edge should reflect a more naturalistic
environment through the introduction of
timber and the natural color palettes
however officers consider the design is
acceptable here a condition requiring
materials to be agreed has been attached
to the recommendation the scale is
considered acceptable in terms of
relationship with a wider site and
neighboring units with regards to
landscaping a soft landscape buffer
would surround the application site
although this is not to the extent shown
within the outline application it is
still considered to provide a sufficient
landscape edge here species meets
planting density and maintenance
arrangements and not been provided and
but a planning condition requiring less
detail has been attached to the
recommendation
chairman this application is recommended
for approval subjecting additions as set
out in the officer report and addendum
thank you thank you have a speaker on
this mr. diamond
up to five minutes I'll let you know
when you put a minute to go
Thank You chair my name is Nick diamond
I'm a director at GL Hearn and planning
consultant to the applicants Henry Vogt
developments the application before you
is the first in a series of reserved
matters applications which had to come
forward on the business park and deliver
the vision set out within the joint area
action plan the principle of development
has been established by virtue of the
2016 outline permission which seeks up
to 80,000 square meters of modern office
and industrial uses on the site this
reserved matters application has been
prepared within the approved parameters
of that outline permission and will
provide some 11,000 square meters of b1
b2 floor space the supporting planning
statement and design and access
statement explains that the building has
been designed to complement its
surroundings as well as the wider
landscape and settings the proposal will
facilitate the long term aspirations of
IP Co who are currently located in a
number of units across aviation way and
allow them to consolidate and retain
their operation within the district
the proposal therefore specifically
responds to IP COEs operational and
parking requirements the issue was just
raised by your officer in relation to
the minimum bays and that exceptional
circumstances has been demonstrated this
fundamentally comes down to the fact
that the proposal is to accommodate IP
Co specific requirements in summary the
proposal is the first phase of
development on the Business Park it
complies with planning policy and will
deliver first-class flexible employment
space for a long-standing local employer
we welcome the officers recommendation
and trust that members will see fit to
approve the application before you this
evening thank you for your time thank
you members on page 6.1 we have some
recommendations with two additional
conditions printed on on the addendums
conditions 7 & 8 do any members wish to
speak on this one that's a step down
Thank You chair with reference to the
entrance onto aviation way it's going to
be controlled can officers just point
out on the diagram where that's going to
be located it says in the addendum that
it's a nother plate recognition system
that's okay for vehicles that are
registered with the company company
vehicles etcetera etcetera but how will
delivery trucks be dealt with in that
situation where they need to be pre
registered before the before they can
deliver or will there be somebody there
to actually take calls to allow people
in and out thank you anyone else wish to
speak that's the whole quay just a
couple of questions it's the parking
area to the north of the building solely
for mmm the staff or is it for is there
visitor parking spaces I was part of
that parking area or are they meant to
be parking in another area and as the
building is adjacent to the a green area
there was mention about the how the
building sort of like fits in with we've
reversed sort of luck and neighboring
sort on green fields and stuff like that
what would the would normally happen to
the the building is it to do with the
the sort of color of the clad in how it
blends in is that the issues that that
was of concern
so just in answer to the gate control
query we don't have detail with regards
to precisely how that would operate at
the moment in terms of delivery trucks
and actual general access arrangements
that would be something we had a
condition which we impose in the
previous application and that we had
here which approved that spine Road so
just to confirm this is this spine road
was agreed as part of the previous
reserved matters application the gate
control access would be somewhere in
this
occasion but obviously now we've got the
additional access here for the service
yard County highways are said to ensure
a 15 meter distance back for HGTV's but
in terms of the actual how old of gates
do controlled access we would deal with
that but that by the discharge condition
which we would need to be addressed
through the form previous application so
we'd get all that level of detail agreed
with County highways as part of that
discharge or condition request Jennifer
if I can't come right back on that as we
haven't got those details can I propose
that once they come in it's done in
conjunction with the ward councillors
place
[Music]
do the other questions
we can certainly as part of that actual
condition requirement come back to you
it's not we've had conditions previously
that have had reference to consultation
with members or parish within the
afterword in the condition we can't
amend that now because that's already in
the formal application condition wording
but we can make a note to come back to
our members when it comes to discharge
in that condition and in relation to the
parking for the staff and visitors to
the north so yes that would be staff and
visitor parking within that area and
that would be provided for there we've
agar see actual color of the cladding
yes I think County urban design their
concerns were the normally on that kind
of age they wanted it to try and sort of
blend in the more rural environment so
perhaps the coloring and the actual
nature of the cladding a more perhaps
timber type appearance in material and
coloring and would be perhaps what
they'll be looking for and but I think
that has been considered as part of this
application and we don't object as
officers to what we've seen in terms of
material palette that's come forward at
the present time but we have got a
condition that we've imposed anyway with
regards to a material detail to be
agreed and we have got quiet
I mean whilst it is on the sort of age
year we have got sort of quite
commercial units along here which don't
use that kind of sort of natural palette
so obviously taken up to consideration
as officers when we've considered this
application okay members as mentioned
the recommendation for approval is on
six one with item seven and eight on the
addendum we've mentioned the information
about what counts has been made aware of
the proposed gating Arrangements those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate thank you that item is approved
next we have item seven new airport
terminal building at Southend Airport
sorry Thank You Damon this application
relates the airport terminal building
planning permission is being sought to
vary condition to planning permission
reference number 17 oblique zero zero
nine nine six oblique ful under section
73 after Town and Country Planning Act
1990 condition two relates the
previously approved plan numbers imposed
on the original consent which allowed
extensions to northern and southern end
of the terminal building the location
planning front of you outlined in bold
illustrates where the proposed
extensions will be located in front of
you if you can see those elevations it
just shows the front elevation the rear
elevation and both the northern and
southern elevations of the building and
the variation being salt to northern
extension relates to a slight decrease
in depth the roof form would comprise a
curved roof with a central area flat
roof this area flat roof would
incorporate roof lights the roof form
would not be overtly visible from the
highways it disguised by a parapet and
the operational baggage area which is
outlined in bold in front of you would
no longer be fully enclosed to the
western edge of the extensions the main
roof would protect over this area and an
aluminium mesh screen would be erected
along the western edge this will
segregate the operational baggage area
from the return route area the purpose
for altering this area of the extension
is due to further ground investigations
established that foundations of the
previously approved Western elevation
would impinge on the existing
underground surface water continuation
tanks alterations are being made to the
southern elevation the southern
extension I'm sorry and the southern
extension proposed be slightly enlarged
and the roof from altered to include a
curved roof with areas of flattery
bordering this would visually enhance
out what was previously approved I've
done a comparison plan which if you can
see that and you can see that the chain
Jews proposed are minor and the design
and form of these extension would still
mimic the terminal building and
therefore not consider called undue
demonstrable harm as part of this
application was also proposed to I have
a discharge a number of conditions or
vary the wording to suit the revisions
to this scheme the discharging revisions
to the conditions are considered
acceptable the proposed development
complies of policies relevant to this
application and has been recommended for
approval subject to the revised
conditions and with all other conditions
to remain the same as originally imposed
on on application 17 oblique zero zero
966 oblique ful so out on page seven
point one of the agenda and onwards
thank you very much okay thank you
Thank You chairman I have asked another
counselor what this means but nobody
seems to know condition six brw am can
explain what that is yes a seabream M it
tests M houses make it sustainable
there's a criteria that buildings must
meet and to provide sustainable
development and the bream is is it's a
criteria that just sits out this and
they must have called with with that
we've got a policy in a local plan that
refers to the bream assessment and the
dream of the H building has been
assessed if it goes ahead as good and we
have a standard that it must be good or
very good and that's that's what it
refers to to sustainability of that of
that building
I will inform you have you got off top
you have now okay we'll put that as yeah
but not entirely relevant to determining
the application but it's about
sustainability
alright so relatively minor alterations
in the graph in the grand scale of
things and discharges some conditions
members the recommendation for approval
is printed on page seven point one
through to seven point four those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate thank you that item is approved
right next we move on to the first of
our referred items from the weekly list
which is roasting nurseries Borough Hall
Road boiling magna again this is an item
that has some information on the
addendum given our problems with the IT
we're just going to making sure
everything works each before we start
each presentation
[Music]
yeah Thank You chair good evening good
evening members is it on mm-hm
okay so the application seeks permission
to the principal only of development for
24 Wellings
at a site in the Greenbelt I'd like to
show you so there we are there's the
site sites itself so what we have to the
south of the site is barrow haul road
and going to to the left of the site is
bailing road so currently the site as
you'll see members there are two
bundlers occupying the left-hand corner
of the site the remaining path the site
was a former nursery area and I've got
some photographs just to show members
what the site is like currently current
day so basically access layout design
citing an external appearance have been
reserved for future judgments so the
only issue that we're looking at members
this evening is the principle of
development I'm aware that there are
some indicative elevation plans that
have been submitted in support of the
application but they're indicative only
and the purpose of those I think is to
indicate that at a future stage should a
principal consent be granted they're
just providing a flavor in terms of what
may follow I think what is quite clear
from the linear developments upon a long
darling road and Bera Hall Road it's a
linear development form isn't it with
dwellings facing the the actual street
and then you've got a cluster of built
form on that corner as well having new
we're bailing rod comes on to Borough
Hall Road if we could move onto the next
slide please
so again that's just it blown up so what
we have there is the as members will not
from the report the site is unusual in a
way because it basically follows the
boundary lines of four properties which
is marrying thin tree clematis and fo e
so obviously the devel
to set out to one side of those
properties the two bunglers the left
would be demolished than to make way for
built form with the developments of the
remaining site also we could move on to
the next slide okay so basically there
we go
this shows I just get the pen although
it's a principled consent that has been
sought there's a means of access propose
potentially its it seeks to show where
access could work so there's one point
of access here and an access road into
the site comes round here and then comes
back out here the other side of these
properties here so this is just although
even the layout is reserved it is just
the planners sought to demonstrate how a
development in principle may work within
this site taking into account the
vehicle axis that would be required to
serve those dwellings and what we can
see clearly is that the area currently
occupied by the by the two bundlers
there are three dwellings facing
barreling rod and the indicative plan at
this stage at least shows that's the car
parking will be to the frontage of these
three properties practically basically
reversing on sue balling roared as a
means of getting out further on and back
up towards Rochford and and shopped and
etc so that's just an indicative so you
must remember that this is indicative
only but it is helpful because the
reports a path report does mention the
quantum of developments so even as
outline stage it's helpful to know in
terms of would it meet the principles of
technical housing standards on garden
areas etc although that isn't the
specific issue here I think in principle
we have you know we've got a layout
we're not saying we're not commenting on
the layouts because it's the design is
reserved but that's just an indicative
if you can move on please
we'll move on past that thank you
and yes and further on to do some
photographs just the next one so I'm
aware that you'll be looking at some
photographs later on anyway but this is
the junction of Barling roared with
barrel all roared and that is one of the
bungalows in which one of those three
three dwellings I showed you on the plan
would occupy so they're quite well set
back from the highway actually these two
bungalows and then the area remains open
behind these bundlers walk onto the next
photograph so there we are - bungalow
sitting and it was a hedgerow here that
- the boundary of the site which is
referred to by the arborist in terms of
the early beech tree specimens within
this hedge so it's you know it's quite
screened actually on that elevation move
on for next photograph please okay so
there we are in terms the purpose of
showing you this photograph is in terms
of the road network the the western part
this part of the site you can see
there's a good boundary here the road is
quite narrow as I've been walking along
this road what is clear is that there is
a highway verge haiwa verge being an
area of land at least a metre from the
edge of the actual vehicle a carriageway
is highway verge notwithstanding that
this is only a principal application for
consent there is some space between the
raw edge and actually the actual tree
growth here but it narrows down as we go
along then go on to the next shot please
that's just looking down barreling
roared and what I wanted to demonstrate
to you that is a footpath cam coming
down here but obviously there isn't a
footpath along Borough Hall Road move on
to the next photograph thank you and
that's just a shot looking up towards
and shopped and shopped and Road is it
that towards Rochford and Southend we'll
move on and there there we go so you
I'm aware perhaps you'll be looking at
this road network what what what is in
terms of not sickly I just wanted well
on it too much but what it actually I've
noted from the site visits is that the
the white line in terms of Road actually
doesn't seem to DMACC it's not running
along the middle of the actual
carriageway which may give rise to
problems but we'll move on I just want
to show you a few more photographs so
that is a shot of of the bundler looking
through the hedge so you can see that
the quite wants setback within their own
grounds okay the next one please we'll
move on from that one and two so here we
go these are the other dwelling houses I
mentioned then Foley meringue clematis
and then the access actually would come
out the that wealth the indicative
access at this point it's not definitive
would come out in this area here beyond
so that's the upper proposed indicative
access so we'll just I've just got a few
more photographs to show you members and
that's just just to demonstrate that at
that center of that indicative access
the road is very straight I don't wish
to come any more than that on that right
so in terms of the characteristics of a
site I think this is key actually in
terms of that we know that the the
characteristics of the Greenbelt is is
the very essence of what Greenbelt
policy is trying to safeguard and this
is a shot just taken to the west or the
left-hand side of the of the cluster of
houses looking into the site so the
bundles that we looked at earlier that
they're more down here so that gives you
an idea of what the site is like now
it's quite open and devoid of any built
form so we'll just move on and that is
another shot looking head-on into the
site and then we've got this boundary
here so it's quite so sort of sizeable
sites obviously not point nine one
hectare so that
relates to 9000 square meters as
hectares of 10,000 square meters so but
9,000 square meters in total will just
move on and wrap up on these photographs
and that's another shot just looking
through into the field so what we're
looking at here members are the the tops
of the roofs of the houses along
barreling roared here I just move on I
think I'm almost concluded on my
photographs and that is a photograph
taken from the hedge in between the two
bundles at the western end of a cites
are looking up into the site so I just
wanted to give you an idea of how it
looks as of this week really and that's
how it's been it's quite open and devoid
of any of any built form so we're just
the last photograph and that's just
another closeup so what we have is there
is a little bit of undergrowth and sort
of shrubbery and trees growing on site
so I just like to thank you very much
for that I just like to just pinpoint
the key points in the report there are
three considerations in paragraph 12 of
the report paragraph 14 in terms of the
the greater impact on openness of a
Greenbelt than the existing development
so members will not from the report but
there's two elements to this is that
where the the bungalows occupy that
could feasibly be considered as
previously developed land now I think
members will appreciate from the report
the relevance of the previously
developed developed land consideration
and the glossary of the National
Planning policy framework what you have
here sets out the definition of
previously developed land and the
conclusions and the report is other than
that the site of the two bundlers occupy
it doesn't qualify under previously
developed land because the land as far
as the local planning authorities
concerned otherwise was used as a
nursery for propagating for growing
plants and agricultural land as defined
by section three three six of a tunnel
country Planning Act is not does not
come under
she developed land so as a matter of the
default position this is inappropriate
development in the Greenbelt given that
the built form within that NOC 9 one
hectare site would actually develop that
site the built form would be greater
than the massing of the built form
within the site currently and hence it
would be inappropriate and it would be
again it would be contrary to policy
just to conclude then in terms of the
the paragraph 22 describes the essential
characteristics and the the greater
impact on the openness of a Greenbelt
and that is also a key consideration and
as this developed would have a greater
impact than the default position is that
it it's it would be contrary to policy
so the conclusions that we've reached
that it would be an appropriate
development I'd like to just point out
as well is that members may be aware
just in passing that there have been a
couple of Appeal decisions on a site
which is forms part of the curtilage of
one of the it's just to the where
members assured you were straight road
where the potential access could be to
the site and an and I and the exit there
was an appeal decision there were two
applications and two appeal decisions
for in respective residential
developments on a sites that actually
where the access comes out it's it's
part of this development site and I
think what I'm referring to there is is
that consistent for many years now the
Greenbelt policy exists who safeguard
lien belt from development and
consistent with the the previous
application for a smaller scale
residential development on part of this
site is that there's a consistent
approach the policies in respect of
Greenbelt developments have not changed
and therefore the policy position hasn't
changed
I just like to finish off by indicating
that we're aware of the consultation
responses were aware that they were many
representations of concerned of concerns
received from the public particularly in
relation to highways and also Sutton
Parish Council commented notwithstanding
the Greenbelt issue just to conclude the
flood the areas in a flood zone one so
the flood risk is relatively low but
there is a currently a holding objection
from lead local from the lead local
flood authority vehicle access although
indicative only we have a response from
Essex highways as as included in the
addendum although I don't think that
basically the condition suggested would
be something for consideration at this
stage because of the it would be a
subject at reserve matters but perhaps
it is appropriate sooo when we look at
quantum of development perhaps it is
appropriate to consider to a degree the
the principle of highway access as it is
in terms of the principle of flooding so
there's a holden objection and there's
also an hope there's an ecology
objection from the the county ecologist
and also on a tree on the tree survey
that would be required so culminating in
four reasons for the recommendation to
refuse this application thank you thank
you have a speaker on this one counselor
Cohen from balding Magna Parish Council
thank you there are many objections to
this proposal and it is not possible to
do justice to those objections in five
minutes
those objections include but not
exclusively the erosion of the green
belt health and safety issues an
increase in the flood risk overloading
the surge capacity overburden and the
utilities increasing road traffic
increasing car emissions increasing
street parking insufficient
infrastructure with pressure on schools
doctors and country roads the loss of
privacy to existing residents increased
noise pollution no account whatsoever of
the impact on the local wildlife and
habitat destruction of the amazing open
vistas and skies around Barling
inappropriate development out of
character with the area and street scene
setting a precedent for further
development I will try and address a few
of the points we are all mindful of the
pressures upon the district council to
allow planning applications for more
housing but this scheme is beyond
reasonable this is a proposal for 24
three-bedroom houses to be built in the
main on Greenbelt in a rural setting
with proposed exits onto a narrow
hazardous country road with extremely
limited visibility green belts were
introduced to prevent intrusion onto the
countryside Tom fields of the campaign
to protect rural England is reported as
saying we are being sold alive our many
developers as they sell off and gobble
up the green belt to build low-density
unaffordable housing young families gone
struggling to afford a place to live the
affordable housing crisis must be
addressed with increasing urgency whilst
acknowledging that far from providing
the solution building on Greenbelt only
serves to entrench the issue he went on
to express concern that Greenbelt is
being eroded at an alarming rate I would
like to make a brief reference to the
case of Fox land and property limited
who had been refused planning permission
by Castle Point Borough Council to
develop green belt land of leave lands
thunderously
but wherever a residential development
of up to 165 dwellings the Inspectorate
had remained recommended that the appeal
by Fox land be allowed and planning
permission be granted but the Secretary
of State disagreed with this
recommendation in dismissing the appeal
and refusing planning permission the
they concluded that the proposers were
an inappropriate development in the
green belt he identified harm to the
green belts openness and harm to the
green belts purpose of preventing urban
spread preventing encroachment on the
countryside and preventing the merging
of neighboring settlements and harm to
green belts character and appearance
this represented a considerable harm to
which he attributed substantial weight
the Secretary of State was concerned
that a decision to allow this appeal for
housing in the Greenville risked setting
an undesirable precedent for similar
developments which would seriously
undermine national green belt policy a
conservative estimate 24 houses means
the likelihood of at least 48 cause if
not more Borough Hall Road is narrow
with few passing places for larger
vehicles there is no payment nor
instantly realistically room for one the
traffic speeds into Borough Hall head on
into an a of narrow dangerous Bend and
this is where it's proposed to access
the site on a dangerous blind Bend there
are serious concerns at the anticipated
increasing traffic using Borough Hall
arising from a 320 anticipated dwellings
in Starr Lane and the planned 120
swellings at the liquor Wakering under
Borough Hall road with sole access to
this site being in Barrow Hall Road in
reality there is no safe sighting for an
entrance to this proposed development
there are no shops no schools in the
hamlet there is no employment in the
immediate vicinity more houses means
more traffic on country lanes including
shopping road a notorious accident
hotspot bowling is favored by walkers
horse riders are most definitely by
cyclists increased traffic will increase
the risk of accidents and interest to
these groups the reference to a wet
ditch is mucking brook which is an
important main water course-taking drain
water from the South Church side of
South End in times of heavy rain this
waterway has overflowed and bowling road
has become almost impossible
downpours resulting flooding at the
junction of bowling road and Borough
Hall the current systems are not coping
and this before the added burden of
further 24 houses
- already stretched drainage system
exacerbated by the impact of building on
land which would otherwise absorb the
rainwater to offset the flooding risks
the
has claimed that this development will
enhance local character is fiction it is
in stark contrast to the nearby listed
cottages and will forever ruin the
appearance of a pretty and appealing
Hamlet the developers claimed to enhance
and maintain the vitality of this
already existing rural community cannot
be achieved by introducing 24 houses
with associated cars traffic noise
pollution and loss of privacy by
adjacent properties 40 or more residents
of this parish felt strongly enough to
take the trouble to log their view onto
the District Council's planning comment
page this illustrates the strength of
feeling within the community they do not
want an inappropriate and over
development of their hamlet I would urge
that their views are given weight
ultimately at the end of the day it is
they who will pay the price for this
over development and they should not be
treated shabbily do we really want to
deny future generations any rural
countryside around Southend and Rockford
with this beyond legacy to destroy what
is left of our green belt in rural life
I sincerely hope not do not portray your
residents by allowing this unacceptable
bosal counts less Stanley Thank You
chairman it would it would look to be
that 2026 houses in a small hamlet of
under 26 hours these would be
overpowering to the hamlet in itself
apart from the surface water management
which would would indicate that it's
already been indicated that it does
flood where in those areas it's it's
just an inappropriate development
especially in the green bill I feel that
yes they can perhaps put another
building where the other two bungalows
are make it three but that's that's
everyone one more than what is already
there I do feel that the the way it's
designed as to drive in and out is
really really very dangerous to the to
the corner where vehicles will actually
sort of come off the corner if they
don't watch out they'll be collide you
need the vehicles come in that
area so yeah um I'm not at all happy
with this development at all thank you
thank you that's the scepter Thank You
chairman whilst their officers are
loading up my photographs I've called
this in sometime ago mainly because of
the lack of reports from various
consultancy bodies in particular
education Essex the Environment Agency I
mean in particular the highways the
applications should have come before
this committee at the last committee
meeting but for one reason or another it
was missed off the agenda I find it very
strange that two days before the week
added before our committee that we get
an addendum listing the issues around
highways I find that a little strange
and I will be questioning in that
further at highways with regards to the
presentation I feel that committee has
been slightly misled and I'll explain
why first of all the picture I show you
there I'd like you to take note of the
telegraph pole that it's got the
transfer [ __ ] just make a mental note
of that please if I could have picked a
two please
this is where I'm standing by the side
of that telegraph pole which is where
the second entrance and the main
entrance to the site is that wasn't
mentioned earlier on and I'm having to
stand right on the edge of the road to
be able to see around the corner
can you imagine what what car would be
like to come out at that point and again
please notice that there is very little
markings on that road there in picture
three please you'll notice I've had to
walk down to that white wall before I
can see around that corner and you can
just see the main junction that the main
junction there which is Barling Road
which is the main roadway that comes
through although the traffic is filtered
into this road the actual main road runs
down in this picture to the right
picture for please please know that
vehicle is just standing roughly where
that telegraph pole is you can just see
the telegraph pole coming at the top of
the hedge and you can see the width of
the road it's not wide enough for two
cars to pass at that particular point
and just in front to the right of that
vehicle you can see the entrance not the
one in the foreground the one further
back in the picture that is the existing
entrance to the site and that is where
the main entrance on the plane is not as
suggested in the presentation further up
the road picture five please this is a
car going in the opposite direction
again to just give you an indication of
the width of the road you you can see
there how narrow that particular road is
picture six please
again you can see the vehicle move down
very slightly and again you could see
how long about how now the road is also
notice the slow sign that covers more
than half the width of the road again
they're sustained at slow sign and it
shows you the width of the road and note
there are no Center white line in there
because a road is simply not wide enough
to put it it's a certain place this is
you can see where the bungalows are and
this is looking up to the main site
there the road there is is over the
hedges overhanging although the officer
suggested there is a piece of highway
along that edge it isn't maintained by
highways as part of the contract
so there is currently no footpath there
and to walk around that corner in either
side of the road is a very dangerous
corner picture right please gather way
up would be very helpful that's it this
is a note a picture of me driving the
car please note that I wasn't taking the
picture of my passenger was laying it
across taking it so don't get in trouble
with I'm using a mobile phone you could
just see where that telegraph pole is
just in the middle of the pit almost in
the middle of the picture there and you
can see how far I've had to come forward
before I can even see where that
entrance is that telegraph pole even if
you remove the hedge will still remain
in the way I would like to suggest and
propose that a number of additional
reasons for refusal are added to the the
paper with regards to the roads there
the roads are very narrow
there has been no allowance for putting
any additional footpath in moving that
telegraph pole and I know it's going to
be difficult to move that because it's
got the main power unit in there and
that does feed all of the properties in
that area
so that's going to be a difficult job I
do appreciate with 24 potential houses
there's going to be quite a considerable
number of people wanting to go to school
the bus stop you would have to revert
walk back
behind where the car is in that picture
there a fair distance round round the
roads where there are no footpaths to
the bus stop I would suggest that we
need to put on in there that the bus
stop is relocated into the bowling road
where there is currently a footpath and
that would be far more sensible a much
safer place for buses to to go buses
don't actually come down Barling a
barrel Hall Road there they come down
Barling Road so and I'd also like to see
a contribution towards education because
there's going to be an additional cost
for the bus ease etcetera etc the Junior
School incidentally is some considerable
distance away to two and a half miles
and again there will be a need for
looking after the children there with
regards to the water runoff of the site
it is downhill from this this point
behind the car it's quite a steep slope
and it does run quite quickly it runs to
the water course that was mentioned by
the chairman of Barling Parish Council
it is the main water course it is
monitored by the environmental agency
and I'm surprised that they haven't
commented on this it does take the ward
main water feed out from the hold of
South Church in South End comes down
through our district and it does flood
quite frequently there is a property
just around the corner there fairly
recently where the water run over the
road and the water was running in front
door and out the back door which is not
the most pleasant thing of in the world
so that needs to be taken into account
and I would want to see something on
there with regards to attenuation tanks
control of how that water is let into
the into the stream chairman I would
like to propose all of those things and
some of the word he may have to be
worked with the officers and I would
also like to include all of the points
that have been raised by highways in the
addendum that they should be included
within the in the report because
currently they are not
and that also includes the import
formatives thanks yeah queue before
before we move on I think we've got a
few issues with some of the things that
you've you've mentioned because what
we're looking at here is the principle
of whether development should take place
everything else is then reserved the
principle of whether highway access is
possible
everything else is then reserved so to
be talking about water attenuation tanks
or on-site it's just not appropriate at
this moment if you look to point two on
the officer recommendation for refusal
there's clearly a point there that
describes how there is no effective
surface water drainage strategy and
that's I believe that is the appropriate
level that we will be working at for
this for the nature of this application
which is principle with all matters
reserved so would you like to come in so
for the first one the the roads and the
highways access is not for determination
so the specific access points onto the
the highway we we can't reasonably put a
reason for refusal together in relation
to the the roads being narrow in
relation to the vicinity of the site its
what hasn't formed a reason for a few so
from an officer perspective because
County highways believe that in
principle an access point can be
delivered onto the highway that is safe
and it is a maintained highway albeit
with pinch points at certain points but
it operates with road traffic on it at
the moment and they would not support a
reason for a futile around the highway
that would serve the site not being
acceptable and so detrimental to highway
safety that it should be refused the MPP
F
talks about reasons for fused emotion to
highway where highway impacts are severe
so the difficulty we would have there is
that the high risk Authority wouldn't
support that reason for refusal in
relation to the the road being narrow
when the footpath and the considerable
number of people are using the site and
because of the number at the quantum of
development that's proposed and the
journey on foot to the bus stop
not being ideal I think we could
potentially work those elements into
reason for refusal one which relates
which does reference although it's
mainly concerning the Greenbelt it
references the site not being a
sustainable development being located in
a rural area not part of an existing
residential settlement so I think those
elements of you know the the sort of
journey to the bus stop not being served
by a proper foot way and the other
couple of points I just mentioned we
could perhaps work those into reason for
future one and it support that reason we
in relation to specifically the bus stop
being relocated I think at this stage we
are as officers looking for well we're
recommending refusal on quite you know
four grounds that are you know pretty
well substantiated and I think the bus
stop the proximity to the site and the
not the foot way being not being
acceptable is probably as far as we can
go we're not really looking for this
development to get approval we would be
confident and appealed an inspector
would kind of go with our our reasoning
and on that the bus stop being relocated
is therefore perhaps something that
you'd look for if we were actually going
to get we're looking for approval so I
would say perhaps not necessary to be
dealt with at this stage all working to
a reason for refusal County Education
working were consulted on the
application and haven't requested any
contribution so that leaves us in a
difficult situation in terms of putting
a reason for refusal together around the
lack of an education contribution
because we haven't been told by the
authority responsible
for school provision in the district
that that's necessary and reasonable
coming from this development so we might
have a view on that to response or lack
of a response but we would it would be
very difficult for us as the local
authority not responsible for education
provision to formulate an argument
robustly appeal because the inspector
would want that put robustly that we
could ask for that here so again I don't
think on this occasion we could we could
look at that and then the flood risk I
think is adequately dealt with in reason
for refusal to so that does talk about
the fact that the application hasn't
demonstrated that the surface water can
be effectively dealt with recognizing
the issues of flood risk at the site
from surface water drainage in principle
the land is flood zone one so at the
lowest level of flood risk but we are
still not satisfied that they've put
together a surface water drainage
strategy even at the outline stage that
demonstrates they could it wouldn't
increase flood risk elsewhere so I think
that is all worked into that reason for
a fuse or to having listened to the
offices in yourself counts to step toe I
think this is the the crux of what and
the bulk of what you were saying was
around highway so I think it's for you
to determine whether you want to push on
the highways reasons that you you you
mentioned knowing that County highways
are unlikely to support at this point
sure if I may come back I think there's
a number of items there that could go
forward as an informative because this
nature of this particular site I don't
think this will be the last time we see
it with regards to the highways issues
I'm curious to ask officers had the
highways responded at an early stage of
earlier stage in the process would any
of these items being then taken forward
to reasons for refusal
so I think we can note down for you know
for information for any further
application the points that were raised
and certainly we can work in a couple of
the items I mentioned the respective
condition Emrys and profuse we'll want
to support that the fact that we don't
consider it a sustainable location but
you know the sort of sort of rather late
response from County highways is it's
not ideal but in this situation it
wouldn't change officer's view in this
because the site is served by a highway
an adopted highway it's not a you know
track it's it takes vehicle of traffic
from the surroundings okay this would
increase the amount of vehicle traffic
using that particular location but an
access could be provided that was safe
and so county wouldn't support that
reason for a fuse also I the timing of
that response being received hasn't
changed has had no impact on how
officers would view that then I would
like to see them go for the items to go
forward as an informative because as I
say this is not going to be the last
time we see this application it's going
to come bouncing backwards and forwards
to us for something to make a way
thank you chairman I'd like to concur
with many other points raised by council
step so I just would like for clarity
because we've got the indicative map up
there just to point out what I believe
was a mistake in the original we call as
I see on that that drawer in there the
the access point ease to the to the west
of the the properties that were
mentioned the four properties and in the
presentation the officer showed that the
the
the preferred access point was actually
in the photograph which was indicating
it was to the east so yes it's it's
actually nearer to the the the more
dangerous aspect of the the road there
nearer to the bend and I think
councillor step those photographs and
he's description demonstrate that this
raises the the issue where I do have to
wonder what planet County highways are
on you couldn't find a more dangerous
access point onto a highway and this is
my opinion
not just as a councillor but also as a
licensed taxi driver who regularly uses
this route and has to come across
vehicles coming in both directions where
individuals do have to give way to each
other because of the the insufficient
width of the carriageway there it may be
an existing carriageway but I would
imagine if there was anything that was
likely to be built there you know from
scratch he would never be built to the
conditions that we we that there exist
presently and I think that that it does
need to be raised and I are back the
informative that councillors that so as
raised that this this does need to be in
our report so that any any future
applications that come forward that
there's a background to this thank you
Thank You chairman um could we go back
to the diagram that shows the two
bungalows of the original one that we
looked at just behind the four bungalows
in a row on the nursery site there's a
number of rectangles and squares but
were they all bots are they today yeah
yes as far as I'm concerned there's what
were then historic times of former glass
houses growing propagating sheds but
there's actually nothing there now all
demolished that's right thank you
sorry chairman thank you following on
from councillor step those comments did
Essex County actually come and survey
the site well have they relied on maps
well I have we haven't asked a specific
question and as I know otherwise so my
understanding is they visit sites on
which they provide consultation
responses on much the same way that
officers would visit a site where they
are recommending a determination for a
planning application but the short
answer in this particular situation is I
haven't asked that specific question
often I suppose I presume that they do
visit every site okay members we have a
recommendation for refusal paint printed
on eight point one point seventeen and
eight point one point eighteen which
would have a series of informative x'
added to it and some further working
into item one around the sustainable
development reason for refusal so those
members in favor of the refusal as
indicated plus the informative x' as
outlined by councillor Steptoe and the
adjustment to item one as outlined by
the officers please indicate that item
is fully refused thank you
our next item is item 8.2 bramblehurst
farm hide wood lane kuden if any of our
visitors wish to go at this point feel
free but it's going to be really
exciting the rest of the meeting
okay sorry chairman um so I'm not very
close to that can you hear me this
application relates to the site outlined
in bold here with access off Heidi would
Lane if I can take you to the next and
the layout plan please so the
application site is this area here a
relates the replacement of an existing
mobile home and the erection of a
dwelling house in its place at the
proposal the existing mobile home is
positioned here on the site and this
proposal seeks to remove that from the
site and erect the new dwelling house in
the same position within the plot the
existing mobile home has been granted a
lawful development certificate through
passage of time so it's an application
that benefits from a lawful development
certificate rather than granted planning
permission in the first instance it has
been there for a considerable length of
time so not perhaps exactly the same
mobile home because you can replace them
it's a use of land but the use for the
stationing of a mobile home for
residential use has been going on for
some perhaps thirty six years the key
then take you to the next plans I can
show you the proposed bungalow sorry
they're quite faint but the bungalow
that's proposed to replace the mobile
home has a rectangular footprint a
simple pitch roof form a small porch
detail over the door the key issue for
the determination of this application
lies in the fact that the application
site is in the Greenbelt
and the in planning terms the mobile
home that currently exists is defined as
a caravan so it under the caravan sights
act rather than being considered in
planning terms a dwelling house it's a
use of land for the stationing of a
mobile home for residential purposes
that benefits from the lawful
development certificate and what's
proposed is operational development it's
bricks and mortar with foundations and
that would be considered a dwelling
house so we go to the MPP F in terms of
what is acceptable development in the
Greenbelt and the replacement of a
mobile home with a bricks and mortar
dwelling house which is considered
operational development is considered
inappropriate development in the
Greenbelt which should only be allowed
if very special circumstances exist
which clearly outweigh the harm the harm
in this case so in terms of harm to
Greenbelt openness we think of the scale
of development so that's the
developments height its width its length
but also particularly pertinent in this
example is the degree of permanence so
that is also a factor when you're
considering the the harm in terms of
Greenbelt openness this replacing that
dwelling is not substantial not not
greatly excessive in terms of its scale
in terms of its height its width its
length its nine percent greater in floor
area than the mobile home which it would
replace but officers take the degree of
permanence to mean that in this
particular situation there would be
increased harm arising from the building
of a dwelling a bungalow as opposed to
the positioning on the site of a mobile
home which could be moved from the site
albeit we accept that this one has been
in situations have submitted some
extenuating circumstances which relate
to the medical conditions of the current
occupier whilst the whilst office is
sympathized with these very special
circumstances by their definition have
to be
very special and the fact in this
instance is that the mobile home which I
think it is a little a little old in
this particular case could be replaced
by another mobile home and overcome some
of the issues that are affecting the
health of the lady that occupies the the
mobile home so officers have concluded
that the proposal would amount to
inappropriate developments in the
Greenbelt which there are no very
special circumstances to outweigh the
harm and the recommendation therefore
chairman is one of refusal thank you we
have a speaker on this one Jennings
five minutes I'll let you know when he
got a minute ago Thank You chairman my
name's Kate Jennings of welage and not
and I'm the agent for the applicants the
applicant mrs. Bucknam has been residing
on the site at bramblehurst farm since
1982 when the pig enterprise was first
established planning permission was also
obtained at this time that was the first
time that planning permission was
obtained for the mobile home on this
site the mobile home on the site has
been in 6:u in the same spot but it was
replaced in 1995 after a fire but
throughout this time it's been Miz's
Buckinghams home the agricultural
activity on the farm ceased in 2001
following the pressures from the general
decline in pig prices leading to the
loss of a contract and then the eighth
outbreak of foot-and-mouth disease and
very very close to home when it was no
longer viable to rear pigs on the site
mrs. Buckman remained living on site and
in 2017 a certificate of lawfulness was
granted by RDC for the continued
occupation of the mobile home the
original permission was a temporary
permission tied to the agricultural use
but as I said the agriculture use ceased
for reasons beyond her control the
proposal is seeking the replacement at
the mobile home which is now 22 years
old with a very modest sized dwelling
the benefits of the replacement will
mean insulation and energy efficiency
measures can be put into place and
improve the living standards for mrs.
buckingham and reduced her living costs
mrs. buckingham is retired and also has
health issues which do not benefit from
the damp and drafty conditions she is
currently residing in and this
application was supported by a letter
from mrs. Buckinghams doctor who
confirmed a permanent dwelling would be
much more beneficial to her health we
are in agreement with watcher district
council offices that the mobile home is
not a building by definition but it is
the temporary structure but it's a
temporary structure that has permanent
permission to be on site without any
restriction the council have confirmed
that the current Caravan can be replaced
with a similar or larger caravan rather
than allow a new bricks-and-mortar
dwelling the size of any replacement
caravan in this situation is controlled
by the control of caravans act 1960 as
amended by the caravan site in 1968
under this legislation the maximum size
a caravan can extend to is 136 square
meters with an overall volume limit of
about 400 and 14 meters cubed the
proposed replacement dwelling has been
kept very modest and as such represents
a 47% reduction in floor space from the
allowable limit of a replacement mobile
home this in area terms is 70 square
meters less usable floor space proposed
in the permanent bricks-and-mortar
dwelling than the caravan that could be
replaced without the need for any
further planning permission in terms of
volume a pitch roof is proposed to
replace the flat roof to improve improve
the appearance of the building but even
with this addition of volume the
proposal still Falls 20% below the
volume of the maximum size of the
caravan that could go on this site and
that caravan could be sited permanently
without any further permissions it's our
view that the design and appearance of
the proposed dwelling first is an
extended mobile unit which is lawful is
a significant enhancement in the
Greenbelt it is noted that this
application was supported with seven
letters from immediate neighbors who
considered the replacement with a
permanent dwelling would be far more
suitable in in keeping with the area the
residential curtilage associated with
mobile home at bramblehurst farm is
long-established and dwelling has
permission to be sited here permanently
whilst it's understandable the council
want to control sporadic development
each case should be judged on its own
merits and specific circumstances this
residential site is long-established in
the landscape and to assume that if no
one chose to live in a mobile home that
it would be cleared from the site and
return to a greenfield is not logical
given the extensive landscaping around
the site and it's set him in the
farmstead so in summary the main issues
to consider are whether the proposed
development has a great impact on the
openness of the Greenbelt than the
existed permitted permanent caravan or
any successive replacement it's our view
that the full-back position is
significantly more harmful to the
Greenbelt than our proposal secondly
whether the proposed modest dwelling
enhances the appearance of the site and
it's our view and the view of the
neighbors that supported this
application that this proposal does
offer an enhancement
and finally whether the particular
personal circumstances in the history
the long history of occupation by mrs.
Buckingham at bramblehurst farm amount
to very special circumstances which
enable the proposal to be exceptionally
supported in the green belt it's our
view that these do amount to very
special circumstances we would therefore
respectfully ask the members to support
this proposal thank you very much that's
the Stanley thank you German we're
having a lot of trouble with this green
belt of what we got at the moment where
we're allowing anyone basically to put a
caravan on or mobile home and
what-have-you and there are
circumstances where where the building
of this construction is allowed and
those as the officers now is with the
travelers however this this obviously
this person needs probably updating her
residence and by doing so it could be
that she could live a better life
however input in our building on
Greenbelt
which we do not approve of
constructionwise
only into special circumstances and on
this these special circumstances are
being have been foot brought forward in
the case of where we have traveler sites
I don't think this is a proved thing to
do
thank you okay you referred this one
chairman cannot come back later only
after the discussion I think you are the
discussion you know the members discard
right okay counsel Weston yes chairman
just a couple of questions first of all
I understand there was in some of the
report is a watch for District Council
do know an awful sight in the caravan
and then somewhere along the line
furious tan line it was a lawful can you
just go through that again with me
please thank you I don't know if it
helps but if you refer to page eight
point two point four at the bottom of
your committee papers and then
paragraphs labeled seven to twelve that
sets out the relevant planning history
so I'm not sure whether that that has
sort of helps and answers your question
but were dating back sort of 1982 when
we first looked at the sighting of a
mobile home for an agricultural worker
we're then going to 84 renewing that
permission it's then approved in 1996
subject to a condition and then in
nineteen saury 2017 the lawful
developments difficult was granted for
the existing use for the siting of a
mobile home for residential purposes
when it was that when that was approved
was that because the it was in the area
was used as a working area or was it
because the libs no more working on on
the farm itself and that was just the
only thing that was on it was the mobile
home please
so in 2017 the lawful development
certificate that was approved was
reprove on the basis that the the use
for the siting of the mobile home and
it's residential occupation had been
demonstrated by evidence from the
applicant that had been going on for ten
years on a continuous basis so that is
one of the grounds on which you can
apply for a lawful development
certificate and it was demonstrated with
evidence that that used for 10 years
have been going on continually for a
person living in that mobile home that
was not last employed or connected with
agriculture so the concern awful
development certificate that exists
enables it the caravan the mobile home
to be used by anybody as a you know for
residential purposes it's not tied to
any specific person and it's not tied to
anybody last employed or employed in
agriculture at the moment Thank You
chairman statement that each application
should be looked on and its own merits
is something that I agree with an
approve so and there obviously are some
special circumstances relating to this
particular application however we are
all aware that developers like to use
precedence to attempt to chip away at
our policies and the greenbelt and I
despite the circumstances that been put
forward I do agree with what the offices
have laid out for the reason in why they
have refused this
particular application the the
individual still has the right to to
remain living on the site and has the
option of updating her residence but the
actual to change that to provide a
permanent dwelling as described by the
offices I think goes against the
Greenbelt policy and I'm opposed to that
chairman members officers this
application comes from mrs. buck
Buckingham who has lived at bramble
house brand new Hearst farm in the
mobile home since 1982 when the pig
enterprise on this so holding was first
established she has ridden through the
ups and downs of the pig industry and a
fire which cut at her house in 1985 and
was the I was only to be forced to to
close her pig Enterprise at Bramley
Hearst farm due to the poor market
conditions and also ultimately the
outbreak of the foot-and-mouth disease
in 2001 mrs. buckingham has resided in
the same home on site since 1996 and
planning permission exists on site to
live in the home mobile home permanently
in this location
however the mobile home is in need of
replacement and due to mrs. Buckinghams
age and health issues she is seeking to
replace this old mobile home with an
energy efficient and warm dwelling of a
very modest size the council heaven
acknowledged that the mobile home can be
replaced with a much larger property
that exists on site and indeed a much
larger mobile home than the dwelling
proposed under this application could we
could be placed on the site without any
further planning consent such a
replacement mobile home could be
significantly
more intrusive that the modest dwelling
proposed the replacement dwelling been
sought is designed to the smallest
standards that is a three-bedroom
dwelling can be built to so it clears
the clear that missus buckingham he's
not seeking to build an extra extra
travel and home in this location she is
simply seeking to improve the quality of
the dwelling on this site to benefit her
health and stay at home over over 30
years a doctor's letter has been
submitted in support of the replacement
of this stamp and droughty
dwelling with a new dwelling and the
benefits disk could have to mrs.
Buckinghams health the very special
circumstances that exists in this
particular case are in my sufficient in
my in my view is sufficient to support
the development within the Greenbelt in
conclusion chairman as we have heard the
proposed dwelling is significantly
smaller than the full-back position
which is the placement of the mobile
home with us a substantially larger her
mobile home the proposed development is
some some twenty percent smaller than
the bulk and mass that can be lawfully
pulled onto site in the form of a mobile
dwelling the replacement with a smaller
dwelling will have a much less impact on
the Greenbelt and further development
can be controlled by the removal of
permitted development right the
residential courage is established and
lawful on this side this is this
proposed does not extend beyond these
established boundaries so there is no
impact on the openness of the Greenbelt
in this location I think this is a
really finely balanced one from my side
of things certainly the principle of
someone living there that that that's
established it's what they're going to
be living in there's no question that
this particular property is
ready for replacement we do have to be
very careful about precedent and the the
potential impact of that around the
district I think there are some special
circumstances here the protectors from
precedent being being used if we were to
to allow this in that the the length of
time that this site has been used for
residential a common accommodation
clearly demonstrated it's very
significant and without question this is
the this is a modest property just a I
think it's nine percent bigger than
what's already there but on the other
hand people are talking about mobile
homes as if they're a substandard
product nowadays mobile homes do meet
current energy standards they have to
there their lifespan is is in excess of
40 years they are very good at very
expensive products and it's quite true
that a very much larger one could go on
this site than the the actual proposal
that's that's before us but members it
is for us to use our judgment to make a
decision so at this moment in time the
reason for refusal is printed on page
eight point two point eleven which is a
refusal in terms of Greenbelt and it is
a balanced judgment that our officers
have come to and unsupported so we we
need to take a vote on this one so those
members in favor of the refusal as
printed on eight point two point eleven
please indicate
those members against the approval I'm
abstaining on that one so that item is
not refused so cancel er er no do you
like to make an alternative proposal
as part of a motion for approval
can I ask officers if they've got any
other conditions that they they would
suggest to you yes so if the if members
are looking for a motion to approve the
application officers would suggest some
standard conditions and also some
conditions that would satisfy some
aspects of councils policy with relation
to development in the Greenbelt so there
we would seek to ask you to consider the
standard time condition not statutory
requirements on any application another
standard one that we build in accordance
with the approved plans that's standard
that the materials and finish is agreed
that's pretty standard materials
condition that we provide two parking
spaces on the site in perpetuity again
for any residential dwelling that well
that would be a requirement and it's not
something that I don't think they can
achieve and then the council screen
about policy in returns in terms of
dwellings looks to remove permitted
development rights for extensions and
also for outbuildings and finally in
this specific circumstance we would
consider it impertinent to put a
condition on requiring the removal of
the existing mobile home from the site
in its entirety we've suggested within
three months of the occupation or final
construction of the new dwelling that's
just to avoid essentially a situation
where you have both because they might
want to just move it slightly to begin
with so that they can their building in
the same position on the site so
somewhere to live
with regards to the three months period
to remove the the dwelling could that be
extended because whether the three
months will be sufficient to remove the
dwelling it can be yeah I mean it's not
set in stone it's something that we make
a judgment about I think three months is
sort of a standard that we might apply
but if you wanted to suggest an
alternative timeframe I guess it the
reason for the condition is for the
interest of the openness of the
Greenbelt so what you wouldn't want is
too long a period but something that's
reasonable would the officers three to
six months yeah I just wanted to
I mean we're saying three months from
first occupation of the dwelling house
so essentially you've you've you've got
your dwelling house constructed yeah so
we're not saying from from first you
know digging in the setting in the
ground so you've essentially got the
dwelling house built and ready to occupy
and then we're saying all they need to
do is arrange for it to mobile home to
be removed could I just ask did you have
a seconder for that motion
yeah that's seconded okay guys the
Wilson could almost the officers given
that the resident in the mobile home is
it's got permission to live there is
that granted to them personally it was
it to the site it's a site site
I'm sorry one last point I think I think
officers would need to be clear about
the if there is a motion to approve what
the very special circumstances are
because that would need to be put onto
any decision that we issue if that
motion were carried right please the
very circumstance will be missus
Buckinghams health as with evidence from
her doctors and the sustainability of
the non sustainability of the existing
dwelling so that we have a motion for
approval with the conditions outlined by
the officers put forward by counts there
are no second by by counts mr. Shaw go
on then
thank you Jim can I just ask the
officers if they feel that that those
reasons are appropriate what I would add
probably that there's been a lot of
discussion and that you know the
discussion has touched on the fact that
this particular mobile home has been on
the site for thirty plus years and the
the length of time in this particular
case might be different perhaps to other
mobile homes that we have in the
district where we might be concerned
that a precedent might be set and so the
very special tree it's very special
circumstances by definition need to be
very special so it would be perhaps
pertinent to draw on anything you've
considered in this application to be
unusually you know unusual different to
other situations that might be
constitute very special
so don't if you want if you want to
elaborate on the very special what I've
got at the moment is the health
difficulties of the applicant and
evidence by doctors in this particular
circumstance on the sustainability
sustainability
no I think I think where did you want to
add to that just on the hit that special
circumstance argument I'm not sure I
fully understand second floor so
apologies if this already covered but
and something around the the length of
time it's been there as a temporary
build of someone living in it yeah might
be a suggestion to be added okay
so members then the the motion for
approval cope with the conditions and
the special circumstances outlined those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate those against that item is
approved thank you our last item this
evening referred item schooled Hill it's
called hearse farm lock and Roca Newton
does anyone else want to go
[Music]
oh well again Thank You chair so in
essence this application seeks to remove
condition five on approval granted on
the 22nd of June 1984 and the as in Oz
on page eight three point eight point
three point four the condition
specifically stated as follows
which is the section paragraph 14 so not
to studing the provisions of article 3
and class 1 schedule one of the ten
country planning government order 1977
the dwelling shall not be enlarged or
altered without the prior approval of
the local planning authority just to
clarify if this condition were to be
imposed modern-day it would refer to
classes a of schedule 2 part 1 of the
general committed element development
order so that was the the relevant
legislation at that time now
fundamentally as members may have picked
up from the report in terms of the issue
of removal of condition want us to
consider what was the reason for
imposing the condition in the first
place so there were very special
circumstances which justified the
replacement dwelling in the first place
so they just to explain
Skol this farm you've got a cluster of
buildings here and this is the new house
in quite a large curtilage we're not
sure of the origins of this building
here we have a photograph of it but this
is the house here in open countryside if
you move on to next slide please
so in terms of the whole issue of the
granting of permission what that
actually meant was is that it doesn't
say that Planning Commission will
not be granted for a foreign app for
extensions in future but it sets out
very clearly on that consent that you
know the that the the developments will
not benefit from the permitted
development rights conferred by the
order so the only way that an
application would be an extension could
be possible would be through the
submission of a planning application now
just going to the main issue so new
chapters begun with a bill with when the
new property was built we can just move
on a slight I mean just sure the
property as it is current day yes thank
you so this is the property the property
according to the planning records as a
floorspace of one hundred and forty two
point five seven square meters just move
on to the next photograph thank you and
that's the rear of the property and then
yeah they've gone that that is the large
building at the rear we're not too sure
of the origins about building there is
some site history on here and what I
would say is in terms of scold his farm
I think the site history roommate
relates to the cluster that is scold us
farm and this obviously is a new
development as a replacement for the
bungalow what actually is a quite a
quite telling here is that members will
note on page eight point three point
three paragraph point eight that's just
before the submission of this
application it would appear to me that
two concurrent applications were
submitted back in 1983 so members all
north that's eighty three three to six
alterations and extensions existing
bungalow was refused in third of
eleventh nineteen eighty-three and then
well no sorry in 1984 so there was an
attempt to extend the existing bungalow
and that was refused and obviously that
followed sorry the buy point and this
this development then granted
six months six seven months later so
really in terms of the lifting of this
condition now we have this we have to
consider in terms of the the reason
ability and the necessity of that
condition so we have to go back into the
heart of what was the purpose of that
condition in the first place the
planning permission quite clearly
indicates that there was inference that
it was twofold
recognizing that it was an agricultural
workers dwelling where size of
agricultural dwelling is an it is to be
controlled in the interest of
maintaining it within reach of an
agricultural worker but also there was
the second issue of in the interest of
the maintaining Greenbelt openness what
I would say is that the Greenbelt policy
on controlling and the mechanism to
control extensions through the removal
of permitted of Ellen White has been
consistent since then since before this
original application was actually
approved so in terms of lifting or
removing that condition we have to look
at whether the the very fundamental
basis of the imposition that condition
be undermined if it was actually removed
and the answer would be it would be
undermined current policy the green belt
in terms of its location hasn't changed
and policy really hasn't changed in the
mechanisms it applies in terms of
controlling further development
subsequent to the initial developments
approved and that is reflective actually
in policy DM 21 replacement of existing
dwellings and it's so the policy 30 over
30 years later is still consistent and
members will not from the development
plan DM 21 the Planning Commission for
replacements are rebuild an existing
dwelling will be conditioned with
drawing further permitted development or
lights rights relating to the extension
of the dwelling or provisions of
outbuildings than the curtilage of the
dwelling actually just to clarify this
the withdrawal of its development rights
on the original consent does not
withdraw
or classy development which is buildings
within the curtilage of a dwelling house
so there is no control and having a
garage within the curtilage but it
controls actually what is currently
scheduled to pop one class-a alterations
to a dwelling house so consistent with
what's in the report in terms of the
conclusion there is no fundamental basis
to route to exceed the removal of this
condition because the same safeguards in
terms of safeguarding the green belt
from enlargements of dwelling houses
through the removal of PD rights it was
a fundamental and justifiable reason at
that time and to remove it would be
fundamentally undermining policy as it
stood then which is carried through to
modern day so it's my recommendation
that the application be refused on the
basis that there is the ran or very
special circumstances that would
outweigh the the prime policy
consideration that in this instance
thank you no sir Stanley Thank You
chairman looking at the photos of the
two photos that I've seen there's plenty
of room for an extension and maybe the
family do need in the extension there
might be special circumstances in doing
this in Greenbelt as we've already
indicated at the previous one it's no
overlook of anybody from what I could
see and it doesn't look as though it's
going to be harmful as it's all grass in
any case so I think this should and
today standards people look today doing
the extensions of a moderate-sized and I
think we should be up to the 21st
century not back in the nineteen
seventies or eighties or whatever it is
that you're referring to so I do believe
that this should be approved under the
you know we're now living in the 21st
century and families get a lot bigger so
I think this should be approached thank
you
near the members wanting to lose so we
can't see on ER then Thank You chairman
chairman members and officers this
application planning application is
several elements to it it's policy
lawfulness of the planning condition
imposed the permits are developed in
particularly the class a and finally the
full-back position which is a material
consideration to any planning
application starting with the policy
position this has been set out very
thoroughly by our officers for which I'm
very grateful and did not intend to
repeat at a apart to say that it has
very little relevance in this case in my
view chairman we first need to examine
if the original plan e condition imposed
was lawful
I therefore draw the committee's
attention to the practical planning
guide which is issued by the government
to assist local planning authorities
when seeking imposed planning conditions
in my submission to the Chairman I am of
the view that this would be the starting
point for any planning inspectors review
of you in this case you'll be relieved
chairman that I'm not intending to
really up the practical planning guide
however there are a couple of points
within the document which I wish to
highlight to this committee paragraph
206 of the National Planning policy
framework states that planning
conditions should only be imposed where
they are necessary relevant to planning
and to the development to be permitted
in forcible precise and reasonable in
all other aspects the docking also goes
on to state and if I may quote this
German conditioners restricting the
future use of permitted development
rights all changes use will rarely pass
the test on necessity and should only be
used in exceptional cases
Constance's the scope of such conditions
needs to be precisely defined by the
reference to the relevant provisions in
the Town and Country Planning general
permitted development England order 2015
so that it is clear exactly which rights
have been limited or withdrawn area wide
or blanket removal freedoms to carry out
small-scale domestic and non-domestic
alterations that would otherwise not
require an application for planning
permission and unlikely to meet the test
of reasonableness and necessity the Rio
- chairman to reinforce the point should
only be used in exceptional certain
circles it's unlikely to meet the test
of reasonableness and necessity this
this Chairman is what a planning
inspector will focus upon however if the
committee are not with me on this
particular point and consider that I
have not made the case in this regard I
will move on to my next point which I
highlight at the beginning of my speech
I can in fact chairman deal with my
permitted development point and fallback
position together when planning
permission was granted full replacement
dwelling known as the Scarlet hearse
farm
it is quite clear on the face of the
decision noticed that permitted
development was only restricted to the
main dwelling house what are the
implications of this world
well the implications are these under
Class C of the general permitted
development order of 2015 the owners of
scarred Hurst farm can construct a
substantial building only a few feet
away from the rear wall of the their
dwelling house subject to it been no
higher than four metres if it is a
pitched roof and doesn't take up more
than 50% of their garden area officers
within
their report talked about openness
within the Greenbelt I would invite
members to consider what would have a
greater impact on the Greenbelt openness
a modest extension to the main dwelling
house or a la a new large detached
building that this local planning
authority would have no control over
this Chairman is the Planning fallback
position of the owners of skulkers farm
which is a material planning
consideration in my conclusion chairman
my final point is this the current
dwelling on the site was a replacement
dwelling for the original farmhouse
which was constructed prior to 1948 it
must follow that as the original
farmhouse dwelling was constructed
before the planning acts were introduced
permitted development was not restricted
therefore chairman the the same should
apply to its replacement and therefore I
strongly recommend to the community that
the planning permit is granted for
reinstatement of permitted development
right to scout her spa for merv my
motion therefore chairman is one of
approval casts the hoc way Thank You
Jerry it seemed from my interpretation
of council linear Arnie's argument is
that that planning authority was wrong
in its making its conditions when the
building was replaced some 35 years ago
however the officers have argued the
case that they were just following our
policy and Greenbelt policy so I can't
see how that argument stands up and
it would seem that this is another issue
about whether we set precedent we've
development in the green belt again I'm
duty bound to point out that um the last
item we did allow a replacement building
based on very special circumstances and
we specifically just took away ensured
that a bit of development rights in the
green belt were removed so we're asking
ourselves to undo the value of our
decision some short while ago may only
come back yeah I said I'm still totally
unclear as to what the special
circumstances are cause I haven't heard
a specific argument what these extra
special circumstances are to go against
their route can't any other members like
to contribute how's the scepter thanks
you know when we're talking about
extensions to this property would things
like conservatory is that sort of think
aloud in this particular instance
[Music]
yes if we were to remove allow this
application it would enable the ability
to construct conservatories as run in
any form of extension adjusters maybe
come back as well just on the the
queries coming up with regards the
imposition of the condition from the 80s
and it is something as well that we
carry on to the current day has been
evidenced by the previous application
it's something that has been written
although we've got the C the planning
practice guidance material consideration
and and the and what's written into that
equally a material consideration is our
policy and our policy still to this day
and requires us to remove PD rights and
when we're permitting new build
properties in the Greenbelt another
thing to sort of mention with regards to
the the permitted development fallback
is when we're considering fallback
positions and we need to have clear
understanding that it's realistic
likelihood of that PD fallback and being
actually put in place on the ground we
haven't had any lawful development
certificate submitted suggests any out
buildings with reconstructed or when
your argument on that basis or put
forward to us and so it's not clear to
us that that's got a realistic prospect
and necessarily have been imposed on the
site this is a fairly isolated property
I won't know specifically without being
able to look up sort of individual
properties but commonly and what has
happened it's it's its new build
properties in the Greenbelt from around
about the mid to late 80s that's when we
started imposing those kind of
conditions so those that properties that
would predate that kind of time or
unlikely to have those kind of
conditions restricted on them I don't
know if that helps in terms of area of
the houses you might be referring to but
it is commonly from the mid to late 80s
that we started putting that condition
on replacement dwellings in the
Greenbelt if I've got that right
this is a fairly new build if it was the
original building we wouldn't be having
this discussion yes the original
building is unlikely depending on it so
if so you assume is yes yeah no but
unlikely have had that condition
okay members counselor Ayano put forward
a case before approving this but at this
moment in time
it's the refusal that we've got in front
of us on the table
so we'll go to that so eight point three
point six there is a recommendation for
refusal on Greenbelt grounds those
members in favor of the approve of the
refusal refusal please indicate thank
you
those members against the refusal please
indicate five six so that item is not
refused therefore I come back to you can
Selena you all know
would you like to restate your reason in
the motion for approval and the very
special circumstances that would allow
this and then I'll look for someone to
second you German I can only reiterate
my in my conclusion for my speech
earlier that the current dwelling site
was a replacement dwelling for the
original farmhouse which was constructed
prior to 1948 and it must follow that as
the original farm master was constructed
before the planning acts were introduced
permitted development was not restricted
therefore the same should apply to the
replacement and therefore I strongly
recommend that this committee that the
planning permission be granted full
reinstatement of the permitted
development rights to skutters farm
my motion therefore
could you could you outline something
could could you further expand please as
to which elements of what you've just
said illustrate the very special
circumstances I would say that based on
the historical position which was not
carried forward appropriately and
unlawfully so the can I just
yes sorry give you a note of caution if
you're just saying something happened
unlawfully I could actually read it
quite yes yes very special circumstances
or maybe what what what you you you
might accept it in relation to the size
of the original dwelling house versus
the replacement dwelling house and the
fact that the permitted development
wasn't restricted in relation to the
original dwelling house that it's
appropriate now to allow permitted
development the extensions on the
replacement dwelling house okay can I
ask if you've got someone on second you
on that house the Steptoe you now can
have a debate on that issue and
counterclockwise indicated Thank You
chairman across the offices is the basis
of cancer alumina in the Ollie's
argument of special circumstances is
that correct in in terms of planning
logs it would not seem to be correct
I'm in terms of looking at very special
circumstances who obviously trying to
make it it needs to be as unique as it
can be to ensure that we're not setting
a precedent throughout the district I
think if we were just looking at the
fact that it was a replacement running
alone they might be concerned but I
think we've built a little bit more on
that by referring to the fact that the
PD was not restricted on the original
and the fact that the replacement is
actually no larger than the original
property and didn't perhaps have its PD
added which some do now a lot of
properties replacements that we get in
now they actually add their PD in terms
of their actual rebuild this didn't
happen to that property at that time so
I think we can perhaps I think we've
built on that a little bit more in the
very special circumstance and I think we
could go with that members we have a
motion for approval on the conditions
outlined by the officers in the very
special circumstances outlined and sanju
who seconded those members in favor of
the approval please indicate those
against
that item is approved thank you very
much for your attendance evening